what's the best programming language to  learn  if you're interested in machine learning  i would say python just because it's the  easiest one to learn  uh and also a lot of like programming  in machine learning happens in python so  it'll if you don't know any other  programming language python is actually  going to get you a long way  yeah it seems like sort of uh it's a  toss-up question because it seems like  python is so much dominating the space  now  but i wonder if there's an interesting  alternative obviously there's like swift  and  there's a lot of interesting  alternatives popping up even javascript  so i i or are  more like for the data science  applications but it seems like python  more and more is actually being used to  teach like introduction to programming  at universities  so it just combines everything very  nicely  you